datant de la société carbone 4 experts
en questions de climat
je sens par arlette chabot gérard
carreyrou et serge july jean marc
jancovici votre livre s'appelle donc
dormez tranquilles jusqu'en 2100 chez
odile jacob pourquoi faut-il dormir
tranquille jusqu'en 2100 alors c'est une
petite pirouette évidemment quand on
parle du changement climatique il est
très fréquent qu'on met en avant ce qui
se passe ou ne se passe pas souhaité en
2100 d'accord on risque 2° et 3° du
reste l'objectif des 2 degrés c 2 degrés
en 2100 et alors ce titre un peu taquin
est là pour rappeler que les choses sont
déjà en train de se passer aujourd'hui
et que le fait de se focaliser sur 2100
donne une fausse impression de
tranquillité pendant encore très
longtemps
quand on met 2100 partout on se dit
finalement je jette un peu caricatural
alors déjà 2 degrés ça fait peur à
personne
en 2100 en plus tous les gens qui nous
écouteront mort donc bord de l'iss en
mai à l'inversé kordic 2014 est l'année
la plus chaude de l'histoire que 2015
devrait être encore légèrement plus
chaud ça c'est déjà le réchauffement
climatique ou sont des allées non non
vous avez la répétition comme ça de
records qui sont battus d'année en année
c'est déjà la trace de l'homme
donc là on est déjà en train de vivre
quelque chose qui ne se serait pas passé
mais ça fait quelques décennies on est
en train de vivre quelque chose qui ne
se serait pas passé sans la trace de
l'homme
après je le répète une température ça
fait peur à personne
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que les
conséquences de cette affaire sont déjà
en train de s'observer en les
conséquences elles sont agricoles elles
sont sanitaires elles sont du coup par
ricochet géopolitique et c'est celle là
qui sont vraiment ennuyeuse c'est comme
ça que vous montrez que par exemple des
récoltes une une canicule en russie ou
en chine ça provoque entre autres les
révolutions dans mon livre j'explique
que comme des règlements vois je vois le
déclencheur ou un des déclencheurs plus
exactement parce qu'il n'y aurait pas de
printemps arabe 100 pays arabes ayant
pâti d'un radeau exactement mais le
déclencheur de cette affaire il a il
doit très largement à la question du
changement climatique et à la question
du pétrole
la question du changement climatique
c'est que le bassin méditerranéen est en
train de s'assécher
dans le cadre du réchauffement en cours
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est dans
toutes les simulations que j'ai vu
depuis je m'intéresse à la question donc
c'est une conclusion solide
et cet assèchement évidemment affaibli
la production agricole mais il est en
cours suscite en cours celui-là le ca a
perdu 50 mm de précipitations sur les
quelques décennies qui viennent de
s'écouler
ça c'est donc le sas a affaibli la
production agricole et ça oblige ces
pays à recourir s'ils le peuvent à des
importations en quantité croissante et
en 2010 vous avez eu plusieurs processus
qui sont venus rendre ses importations
économiquement insupportable pour un
certain nombre de pays il ya le fait que
dans la suite de la crise de 2009 y
avait pas de touristes en tunisie et en
egypte et donc il y avait pas les
recettes à l'exportation
il ya le fait que le prix des céréales
et prix du pétrole varient ensemble
depuis très longtemps et donc en 2010
vous êtes quasiment ou plus haut le même
que 2008 du prix du pétrole et donc du
prix des céréales s'il faut retenir
c'est le coup j'ai serré vous avez 15 à
20% des céréales habituellement
présentes sur le marché mondial qui ne
sont pas là parce qu'en 2010 vous avez
une canicule terrible en russie les feux
de forêts partout etc et une production
agricole quasiment divisé par deux et
pas d'exportation et au moment où la
russie dix jeunes exporterait pas cette
année dans la nuit le prix des céréales
et des 30%
tous ces pays n'ont pas réussi puisque
leurs recettes à l'exportation était
trop basse à subventionner la nourriture
pour des gens qui doivent consacrer
entre la moitié la totalité de ce qu'ils
gagnent à manger et donc on a eu 10 789
on a eu exactement le même processus que
celui qu'on a eu en france
oui moi je voulais vous parler du
charbon parce que j'ai toujours entendu
dire que le charbon c'était terrible au
niveau effectivement du co2 de la couche
d'ozone et c'est donc c'est un des
ennemis qu'il faut combattre et je
pensais avant d'avoir lu votre bouquin
que le charbon c'était plutôt une
énergie en déclin or qu'est ce que je
constate en regardant vos chiffres c'est
que vous dites le charbon est devenu
l'énergie dont l'essor est le plus
important
et vous dites soixante dix pour cent de
l'électricité en inde 95% en afrique du
sud mais aussi 35% aux états unis 50 %
en allemagne etc
on pourrait multiplier ça vient du
charbon même si ça provoque dix mille
décès par an
la silicose par milliers et c'est alors
comment par exemple la coop 21
pourrait-elle prendre une décision sur
le charbon disant il faut diminuer de
moitié dans les dix ans qui viennent
le shell à l'extraction et l'utilisation
du charbon pour produire de l'énergie
est ce que c'est possible alors que la
coop décide non sauf j'étais de vous
faire sourire à ce qu'on décide que la
sauvegarde du climat est un impératif de
sûreté relevant du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies et qu'à ce moment le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
soient fondées est ce qu'on en voit les
chars et les avions chez les gens qui ne
respectent pas leurs plafonds
d'émissions je pense que si j'avais à
parier mon propre argent sur cette
éventualité s'est pas complètement sûr
que j'irai jusqu'au dernier euro is les
économies l'argent des autres ça c'est
moi mon problème on va dire mais bon de
plus en plus de chats renoncer parce que
j'ai dit ce que j'ai dit c'est que c'est
pas à la coop de thon peut demander le
fait d'arrêter d'extraire du charbon ce
qu'on peut demander à la coop c'est faut
respecter les deux degrés et je m'engage
à la devant la face du monde à le faire
et une fois revenu chez moi je vais
essayer de mettre les choses qui
relèvent de mes décisions domestique en
accord avec cet objectif
il se trouve que le charbon est une
énergie domestique c'est une énergie qui
voyage très peu vous n'avez que 15% du
charbon extrait dans le monde qui passe
une frontière entre le pays de
production et le paye consommation et
vous avez huit pays dans le monde
huit pays qui détiennent 90% du charbon
mondiale à commencer par les etats-unis
qui ont les premières réserves de
charbon au monde et la russie qu'elle
est deuxième donc si les pays qui ont du
charbon ce qui voyagent peu arrivent à
s'en passer
alors on a résolu le problème du charbon
qu'est ce que ça veut dire sans passer
ça veut dire mettre à la ferraille les
1800 en gros centrales à charbon enfin
un peu plus même 2000 centrales à
charbon qu'on a dans le monde dans les
30 ans qui viennent ça c'est les 2
degrés il faut le faire avec quoi on va
le remplacer ça devient la bonne
question est ailleurs dans mon livre je
dis si on pense qu'on va le remplacer
avec des panneaux solaires et des
éoliennes
on n'y arrivera pas dans les temps
impartis donc ça veut dire qu'on accepte
que le changement climatique grappes
d'accord qu'on ne tiennent pas les
objectifs et la seule manière d'y
arriver est de recourir de manière
significative
éventuellement au gaz dans un premier
temps et au nucléaire sinon on n'y
arrivera pas
vous dites 6 et on le remplace par du
nucléaire ça coûte beaucoup
ça coûte bonbon mais que si on louera le
remplace par des renouvelables
ça coûte encore 20 à 40 fois plus que
bombo les renouvelables folle et donner
encore une fois c'est photovoltaïque et
éolien parce que vous avez des
renouvelables qui historiquement ont été
très abondantes dans l'approvisionnement
énergétique regardez les pays
scandinaves par exemple hydroélectricité
joue un rôle majeur chez eux
le brésil fait quasiment toute son
électricité avec des barrages
donc vous avez des pays où les
renouvelables peuvent être très
importantes mais pour ça il faut
beaucoup de montagnes pour
l'hydroélectricité beaucoup de forêts
pour se servir de la biomasse si vous
êtes dans des pays plat densément
peuplées vous ne pouvez pas aider
moyennes latitudes donc pas avec
énormément de soleil vous n'y arriverez
pas avec des panneaux solaires et les
éoliennes pour l'instant le premier
ministre indien au bourget dit nous ne
pouvons pas imposer la fin des énergies
conventionnelles ça c'est important
parce que lance un gros pollueurs et
qu'est ce qu'il est en train de dire le
premier ministre indien sait où on va
continuer à utiliser le conventionnel
c'est le charbon si je peux me permettre
un petit parallèle
quand un fumeur vous dis je n'arrêterai
jamais de fumée ils vous racontent
quelque chose qu'il faut il arrêtera au
plus tard quand il mourra bon donc quand
les indiens vous dise
on n'arrêtera jamais le jamais n'est pas
de mise la seule question est de savoir
si ça va prendre quelques siècles ou
quelques milliers d'années et ça sera
contre leur volonté ou s'ils vont le
faire plus vite que ça ait de manière
organisée mais c'est ça la seule bonne
question pas imposer peuvent pas imposer
la fin des énergies conventionnelles
il faut bien comprendre que le problème
ce qui est en train de se passer en ce
moment avec le changement climatique ça
c'est un truc qu'on comprend pas assez
c'est que ça rajoute un facteur de
pression sur une planète qui
n'augmentent pas de taille qui
n'augmente pas ses possibilités et c est
un moment le confinement de l'espace
pour quelques milliards d'êtres humains
deviendra suffisamment important pour
que ce soit le problème qui s'occupe de
nous donc dit autrement
j'augmenterais indéfiniment comme la
consommation de charbon ça n'existe pas
la seule chose qui existe c'est si je ne
m'occupe pas de le baisser de manière
volontaire à un moment quelque chose que
je n'ai pas désiré s'occupera de le
faire à ma place et le quelque chose que
j'ai pas désiré en général c'est bien
pire que ce que je sais gérer on l'a
évoqué
à l'instant mais quand on lit votre
livre stan un éloge de cette énergique
et le nucléaire c'est pas que ça alors
il n'y a pas que ça puisque j'avais sur
rené oui quand même des amis oui vous
dites que c'est l'énergie qui finalement
fait le moins de dégâts
ce que je dis c'est que pour la
production d'électricité en masse c'est
effectivement le mode de production qui
fait moins de dégâts mais je dis pas ça
parce que j'ai envie de le dire je dis
ça parce que ça ressort de la
littérature scientifique disponible
je vais vous apprendre quelque chose
peut-être il existe dans le monde
une commission onusienne qui s'appelle
une star pour united nations scientific
committee andy effect atomique rayé shon
support très sexy comme non enfin on
comprend bien ce que ça veut dire
et cette commission onusienne existe
depuis 30 ans de plus qu'une autre
condition que tout le monde connaît qui
s'appelle le giec
elle fait exactement le même travail
c'est à dire quelle expertise la
littérature scientifique disponible sur
les effets du nucléaire sur
l'environnement sur la santé etc
qui sait que cette commission a rendu il
ya un an un rapport sur fukushima disant
fukushima ne fera pas un mort dans la
population
personne oui non mais surtout c'est une
révélation je trouve exceptionnel ce
public je dispose est un petit peu plus
kovy c'est pourquoi les pro nucléaires
le club de la fraise d'europe avec jean
marc jancovici qui est expert des
questions climatiques et qui signent
chez odile jacob dormez tranquilles
jusqu'en 2010 vous êtes interrogé par
arlette chabot gérard carreau et serge
july et juste avant la pause jean marc
jancovici vous étiez en train de nous
dire gentiment que le nucléaire y avait
aucun problème que fukushima c'est ça
n'avait pas fait de morts que ça ne
ferait pas plus d'une longue de victimes
c'est parce que j'arrive ohkoshi maria
des journaux mais ils sont pas là où on
pense qu'ils seront dans le stress des
gens évacués
quand vous évacuez cent mille personnes
vous avez des gens qui deviennent
dépressif alcoolique etc
mais le barrage des trois gorges qui a
nécessité l'évacuation d'un million de
personnes fera trancher sur garder dix
fois plus de morts parce que quand vous
évacuer un bilan 15 tonnes que voulait
des racines et ses offres sur la sur la
catastrophe nucléaire elle-même sur
l'effet des radiations les faits les
faits les radios leur a demandé il y
aura pas d 0 vous dites zero oui c'est
pas moi qui le dis c'est que je lui dise
et des nations unies nations-unies
encore une fois on une commission
compétente qui existe depuis plus d'un
demi siècle et qui rihanna qui comptent
les morts
quand il ya des problèmes c'est par les
militants c'est par les activistes et
sépare jancovici c'est les médecins les
médecins depuis très longtemps ils font
ce qu'on appelle des études de cohorte
c'est grâce à ça qu'ils disent que le
tabac c'est pas bon que l'alcool c'est
pas bon et que et c'est donc ils
prennent des gens qui sont soumis à un
facteur dont on veut savoir si il est
ennuyeux ou pas ils prennent des gens
qui leur ressemblent sauf qu'ils sont
pas soumis à ce facteur et regarde si ça
fait une différence et c'est comme ça
qu'on s'est encore une fois que fumer
c'est pas terrible pour la santé et on
connaît même les effets et bien ce genre
d'étude de kort existe aussi pour le
nucléaire
ça a démarré dans un cadre tragique qui
étaient les survivants d'hiroshima et
nagasaki
c'est ça qui a permis par exemple de
montrer que chez ces gens là des effets
qu'on appelle mutagènes c'est à dire qu'
il ya des mutations génétiques chez les
descentes en fait sur général même chez
ces gens là on en n'a pas observé alors
c'est triste dans l'est de passer par là
pour le savoir mais même chez ces gens
là on en n'a pas observé
et en ce qui concerne tchernobyl et
fukushima
cette commission a fait des rapports qui
sont faits de la même manière que les
rapports du giec ster qu'on a compilé de
la littérature sur l'île combien de
mains ce qui est ce qui est su
aujourd'hui comme étant une certitude
c'est que vous en avez quelques dizaines
chez les pompiers de la première heure
qui sont faits très copieusement irradié
donc là il y en a plein qui sont morts
de cette irradiation
vous avez quelques milliers de cartes
chez les enfants au moment de l'accident
qui ont contracté des cancers à la
thyroïde pas les adultes
j'insiste les adultes non parce que la
thyroïde a fini de croître donc elle
n'absorbe pas à grande vitesse de lieux
de radioactives et lui arrive pas grand
chose les enfants oui donc vous avez
cinq civils cas de cancers à la thyroïde
qui font des bords tchernobyl on est au
passé ses vacances on trouve des petits
tigres est regardée sur youtube vous
allez plein de gens qui se rendent dans
la zone interdite de tchernobyl il ya
quelques points chauds où il faut pas
aller sans protection mais l'essentiel
de la zone vous vous baladez sans
protection particulière et d'être un
sarcophage
oui sur la scène est une mesure de
précaution souhaitable mais ça ne veut
pas dire que vous mourrez instantanément
si vous rentrez dans la zone interdite
donc ce kiss kiss son je suis pas en
train de dire que le nucléaire et sans
risque je suis je suis en train de nous
dire en 2015 l'avenir est au nucléaire
lui nucléaire et sans riz c'est vrai que
ça fait des morts mais bâtons qu'on
croit et pas ce qu'on imagine parce que
c'est au fond les gens qui sont
intervenus qui sont morts mais il reste
de la population tout va bien et c'est
tchernobyl c'est pas cool à tous tout
non non non non non non non non vous
déformer mes propos je dis que la presse
française pour appeler un chat un chat
ni sur la france du contraire sur
représentés les dangers liés au
nucléaire
est ce que je dis dans mon livre soit
dit en passant c'est que ça ne tient pas
au danger intrinsèque ça tient à ce que
j'appelle le syndrome astérix qui et
l'empathie qu'on a toujours dans ce pays
pour le petit qui gueulent contre le
gros france sas et en france absolument
et vous n'avez pas du tout le même
discours médiatique sur le nucléaire
dans les autres pays je suis désolé vous
le dire mais en allemagne ça a provoqué
quand même un changement total willy tic
puisque on a supprimé le nucléaire et
que vous dites vous-même ça n'a pas
changé d'un iota
l'évolution allemande en ce qui concerne
le co2 ni la dépendance
ceci dit à cela donc la vie est pleine
de risques parce que comme usagers plus
quel humoriste on finit par en mourir
donc le nucléaire est plein de risques
la question est de savoir si en
recourant au nucléaire vous chasser plus
de risques que vous n'en crée c'est ça
la question est relative et pour ça vous
êtes obligés de faire des comptes
vous êtes obligé de compter les risques
du nucléaire gilles paquin apa jeudi
voulait compter et vous comptez les
risques de pas de nucléaire c'est à dire
des alternatives possibles et là quand
vous comptez les risques de pas de
nucléaire vous vous rendez compte que
ils sont supérieurs aux risques du
nucléaire
c'est juste ça que je suis en train de
vous dire et par ailleurs je suis
maintenant suivis avant dieu pour ne
plus croire au monde merveilleux
donc ce qu'on a devant nous c'est pas le
monde merveilleux d'un côté et où je
rentrais à débarrasser tout y compris
des emmerdeurs des gens qui fraudent le
fisc et de l'autre côté un monde
absolument noire où on empile c'est pas
ça la vraie vie la vraie vie c'est que à
chaque moment on a des choix à faire et
on choisit ce qu'on estime être le moins
mauvais en france a choisi nucléaire et
la france c'est de faire son
d'électricité avec du nucléaire je
rappelle quand même que le nucléaire ne
fait que l'électricité c'est très bien
et que l'électricité et que la
consommation de pétrole d'un français
ordinaire n'est pas très éloigné de la
consommation de pétrole d'un européen
ordinaire ne faut pas croire qu'en
france parce qu'on a beaucoup nucléaire
dans l'électricité on a plus de facilité
c'est la tête qui est le plus du clerc
ou en europe
alors la plus grosse consommation
d'électricité nucléaire par habitant en
europe et même dans le monde c'est la
suède donc les suédois consomment plus
d'électricité nucléaire par personne que
nous et au moment où en france on dit
regardez le nucléaire c'est une
catastrophe
areva est pas foutu de construire un
réacteur dans les temps et les délais en
finlande
que font les finlandais ils en
redemandent ils ont commandé un deuxième
emploi chez areva arrivé à tant pis pour
nous mais ils en ont commandé la
deuxième donc là le débat en france
en fait sur le nucléaire il est
sentimentale affectif et je suis sûr
qu'il ya plein de gens qui en m'écoutant
en ce moment 10 mai il délire
complètement qu'est ce que c'est que ce
concept écolo qui vient d eau défendre
probablement mais encore une fois je les
invite à regarder les chiffres de
manière très dépassionné sur le regarde
on l'a dit et fait est qu'on se fasse sa
propre opinion
à mi mai qu'il soit exclusivement ceux
qui ne sont pas vos amis qui sont les
verts sont depuis tant d'années dans le
combat contre nucléaire oui ils sont
dépendants persique est malade dans
l'erreur oui très loin mais mais ils
sont pas les mêmes études que vous
attendez pardon on va être précis ils
sont dans l'erreur
si ce qu'ils prétendent faire est amené
la moins mauvaise des solutions pour que
mes enfants vivent en paix si c'est pas
ça qui prétend de faire alors ils sont
pas dans l'erreur
donc il faut leur demander est-ce que ce
qu'ils cherchent à faire
très sincèrement au fond d'eux mêmes
c'est de faire en sorte que mes enfants
vivent dans un monde en paix si la
réponse est oui alors je pense qu'ils se
trompent
si la réponse est non là on parle pas la
même chose mais peut-être que il
s'inquiète pour les enfants de leurs
enfants de leurs enfants et qu'ils
élisent les violets déchets nucléaires
qu'on ne sait pas traiter et qui seront
régionaux et yannick donne sur les
déchets nucléaires que je peux vous
livrer si ça vous plaît il se trouve que
dans un endroit où gabon qui s'appelle
au clos vous avez une centrale nucléaire
naturel qui a fonctionné ya 2 milliards
donnés alors beau jeu détail pourquoi
dans le dans le livre est donc cette
centrale nucléaire elle a fonctionné par
8 800 mille ans c'est long c'est plus
que 60 ans et donc elle a fait des
déchets que tout centrales nucléaires eh
bien les descendants des déchets ce que
les déchets eux-mêmes ont disparu mais
les descendants des déchets sont là où
ils ont été formés ils n'ont pas bougé
ils vont pas sauter et figure nous on
pense je vais chez d'exister parce qu'on
est bien vivant dans ce studio et ils
n'ont pas été se balader en australie ou
dans la brousse ils sont toujours là où
ils ont été formés
donc ce que je dis sur les déchets c'est
là aussi on sur représente la
dangerosité de ces déchets par ailleurs
un confinement géologique puisque à au
clos c'est ça qu'on a eues il a duré 2
milliards d'années et je prends un autre
exemple de confinement géologique est un
réservoir de pétrole
c'est de liquider du gaz sous pression
ça peut durer des dizaines de milliards
d'années
deux millions d'années pardon donc le
l'idée que si on met les déchets dans
une couche d'argile ça va nous sauter à
la figure demain matin nous empêcher de
vivre j'ai dit non c'est peut-être pas
sûr que ce soit le cas pour vous parlais
tout à l'heure de l'allemagne
expliquez-moi pourquoi il ya un rapport
aussi étroit entre ce que j'appellerais
le climat d'un côté la science et la
politique de l'eau parce que la décision
de madame merkel en allemagne dont je
rappelais depuis votre livre
qu'effectivement ça n'a pas changé d un
iota de l'évolution est pourquoi at elle
décidé de supprimer le nucléaire en
allemagne
et pourquoi le gouvernement de françois
hollande at il décidé de réduire à 50%
et c est ce que c'est de la politique
ou est ce qu'il ya un sens en ce qui
concerne la politique on peut faire de
la politique de manière noble
oui là je pense que ce n'est pas la
connotation de la question dont la
connotation et et politicienne est ce
que c'est que madame merkel prenons
l'exemple du mal à venir quelle puisque
c'est un exemple qui a été avérée elle
est décidée plus de centrales nucléaires
qu'elle a dû se faire violence madame
merkel parce que si vous vous rappelez
bien si vous vous rappelez bien quand
elle est arrivée au pouvoir
la première chose qu'elle a faite c'est
d'essayer d'inverser le plan schröder
donc je rogers avant elle avait dit il
faut sortir du nucléaire
la production nucléaire en allemagne a
commencé à baisser en 2006 par du tout
en 2011
et quand merkel est arrivée au pouvoir
elle a essayé de faire l' inverse
steria l'a dit je vais faire voter une
loi qui va dire attendez pas si vite etc
pis là dessus est arrivé fukushima et
donc elle a été rattrapé par la
patrouille et la patrouille c'est quoi
c'est que en allemagne pour des raisons
que j'ai jamais pris le temps d'étudier
en profondeur mais un jour il faudra tu
le fasses il ya un terreau
antinucléaires considérablement plus
fort qu'en france mais ça encore une
fois ça procède de raisons affectives
émotive et c'est souvent comme ça que
les peuples se décide à l'historique
culturel on peut imaginer les pershing
on peut imaginer un jour une personne
assez bien au fait des questions
d'énergie m'a dit une explication
possible c'est que le nucléaire est une
énergie qui doit être gérée par l'état
fédéral
est ce que les allemands mc les choses
qui sont gérés par les länder donc
l'état fédéral il n'aime pas trop
peut-être que ça joue de même qu'en
france le syndrome astérix encore une
fois jouent dans le fait que globalement
d plutôt envie d'être en connivence avec
le petit qui antinucléaires donc le en
allemagne merkel a essayé d'inverser la
tendance
et puis elle n'est pas arrivée il ya
quelqu'un qui s'est amusé à faire le
décompte des articles de presse
mentionnant fukushima après fukushima en
europe 90% ou 95% des articles parlant
de fukushima en europe l'ont été en
allemagne
donc il ya quelque chose de culturel en
a qu'il faut chercher à comprendre
encore une fois j'ai pas hollande par
contre j'ai la réponse je pense que
hollande avait besoin des voix des verts
dur comme quoi l expérience a montré
qu'il avait raison puisqu'il a été élu
avec 51 quelque chose qu'on s'en allait
vers fonds 3%
une petite soustraction montre que ça
serait peut-être pas passé sans eux et
les verts ils ont un truc qui les unit
tout le reste les états unis ils ont un
truc qui les unit c'est être contre le
nucléaire on en a parlé tout à l'heure
donc il fallait promettre des complots
nucléaire alors 50% ça aurait pu être 47
62 5 ou 18,2 voilà c'était 50 petite
parenthèse précision fessenheim n'est
pas une centrale dangereuse
enfin une autre vidéo qui a la charge
d'en juger qui s'appelle l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire
1 donc quand monsieur hollande ou
n'importe qui d'autre dif et sonnailles
mais dangereux et doit être fermée c'est
une imposture
j'insiste c'est une imposture monsieur
hollande a le droit de dire pour des
raisons politiques je veux qu'on
supprime annuler un réacteur et donc je
demande à edf qui aimons obligé puisque
je suis son actionnaire de fermer un
réacteur monsieur hollande ce qui serait
déjà une raison un peu meilleur peut
dire pour des raisons économiques je
pense qu'on va consommer moins
d'électricité et donc on va avoir besoin
d'un réacteur 2 - je vous demande de
fermer un réacteur parce que sinon ça va
vous coûter trop cher à entretenir pour
ce que ça vous rapporte ça ces deux
raisons qui sont pas des impostures on
peut considérer qu'elles sont bien ou
mal fondées j'ai pas les impostures par
contre que monsieur hollande 10
il ya une autorité de sûreté qui est
chargée de dire quelle centrale est
dangereuse et qu'elle centrale ne l'est
pas et que par dessus la tête je dise -
françois hollande c'est celle là qui est
dangereuse et qu'il doit être fermé
c'est une imposture j'insiste est donc
la seule corollaire de cette décision
qui ferait sens et de dissoudre
l'autorité de sûreté
donc il n'y a pas de danger sur une son
passage jeudi de cinq noms mais je pose
la question
c'est la vieillesse celui sa cavale en
juger par contre ce que je pense de vous
dire c'est que l'argument de la
vieillesse n'est pas un argument
d'autorité
en ce qui concerne le nucléaire je vais
vous faire un parallèle qui vaut ce
qu'il vaut
si c'était un argument d'autorité il
faut à détruire notre dame dare-dare
puisque je crois que c'est un des plus
vieux bâtiments de paris je ne suis pas
si c'est parce que je suis en train de
dire je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
bâtiment le moins insolite de paris donc
en ce qui concerne une centrale
nucléaire en france on a une logique de
la sûreté qui est que là une centrale ne
doit pas être à tout moment conforme à
son cahier des charges de départ ce qui
est le cas par exemple aux états unis
mais elle doit être à tout moment
conforme au référentiel de sûreté du
moment qui devient de plus en plus
exigeant avec le temps et encore une
fois c'est à l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire dont juger si quelqu'un un
sort de l'hôpital et qui me disent ah on
m'a prescrit ceci fait cela et c'est
qu'est ce t'en pense je veux dire mais
j'en sais rien n'est pas capable d'en
juger ben là c'est exactement pareil je
ne suis pas capable d'en juger par
contre je suis capable de juger du fait
que n'importe qui qui dit fessenheim est
dangereux en n'ignorant ce que
l'autorité qu'on a désigné pour ça dit
comme l imposture
jean marc jancovici est l'invité de club
de la presse d'europe 1 on revient
prennent dernière pause à tout et avec
jean marc jancovici spécialiste des
questions de climat qui signent chez
odile jacob dormez tranquilles jusqu'en
2100 et autre malentendu sur le climat
et l'énergie jean-marc jancovici je
reviens sur cette déclaration ce soit au
bourget du premier ministre indien qui
dit en substance écouter laissez-nous
continuer à utiliser les énergies
fossiles personne ne peut nous imposer
la fin des fossiles est ce que c'est une
déclaration de plus sourit ce que c'est
pas une déclaration qui met déjà c'est
du coup je laime là deux choses en
retirer la première c'est que comme je
disais tout à l'heure le charbon est une
énergie domestique
donc c'est les indiens ont du charbon
chez eux moi je serais à la place des
indiens et on voudrait empêcher
d'utiliser mon charbon pour le bénéfice
des autres je leur dirai pas je suis
d'accord payer donc je pense que c'est
une manière un peu brutale de dire ça
ces accords avaient éveillé
ça résume la coop 21 il faut que les
pays riches payent il faut que les pays
émergents il faut que les pays qui va
profiter pour une mutation d'un monde el
pais et d'un climat stable paye ceux qui
ont un pouvoir de nuisance parce que
c'est malheureusement comme ça que le
monde fonctionne
et qui ont la capacité de les empêcher
d'atteindre cet objectif via un concept
qui fait son apparition c'est la justice
climatique
il en parle justice climatique c'est un
autre sujet là j'étais juste en train de
dire si on se place d'un point de vue de
négociations bête et méchante
vous avez un truc qui vous intéressent
que le climat reste stable
j'ai un truc qui m'intéresse c'est que
j'ai du charbon chez moi donc on discute
bon voila et soit dit en passant comme
les indiens sont pas hostiles au
nucléaire je pense que un des trucs
qu'on pourrait faire si on n'avait pas
le nucléaire on est chez nous c'est
discuter avec eux de la manière dont on
peut les aider à remplacer une fraction
croissante de leur charbon par des
choses qui a eu la font pas peur
et ils ont raison parce que le charbon
fait beaucoup plus de dégâts chez eux
que ne pourrait en faire du nucléaire
la deuxième chose que dit le ministre
indien par contre elle est soumis erroné
parce que il préjuge en disant ça qu'il
est capable de savoir que les
conséquences du changement climatique
chez lui seront pas très ennuyeuse parce
que sinon ils diraient pas laissez moi
profiter du charbon et lydie rennes j'ai
quand même essayé de m'organiser
autrement et ça je suis désolé de le
dire il en sait rien il en sait rien
parce que la science elle-même n'en sais
rien il faut bien comprendre et c'est
aussi ce qui justifie le titre du
bouquin qu'on est en train de faire pour
la première fois une expérience grandeur
nature applicable à sept huit ou neuf
milliards d'êtres humains sédentaires
c'est un grand saut dans l'inconnu le
seul réflation référence qu'on est dans
le passé c'est la dernière déglaciation
où la terre s'est réchauffée de 5 degrés
mais en cinq mille ans quand on voit les
changements que ça a provoqué soit dit
en passant on prend que 5 degrés de
moyenne c'est absolument massif
donc il en sait rien le premier ministre
indien de savoir si un changement
climatique qui se caractériserait par
quelques degrés de hausse en 2006 à
mettre le pays à feu et à sang ou pas il
ne sait pas ça donc ça c'est la partie
répréhensible de sa déclaration qui est
de dire laissez moi profiter sous
entendu il n'y a pas de risque derrière
et je vais juste en profiter ça non par
contre le fait qu'ils disent dans la
barque commune dans laquelle on est payé
moi pour que je passe pas une connerie
1 c'est le témoin fait d'accord c'est
quand même le sujet reset dja sur cher
pour aller vite pour finir de mettre les
pieds dans le plat comme contribuables
français
je préfère mille fois je dis bien mille
fois qu'on aide les indiens à se
débarrasser du charbon plutôt qu'on
mette des panneaux photovoltaïques chez
nous
le premier ministre indien et françois
hollande ont lancé l'idée
toujours en marge de la coop 21 une
alliance solaire internationale pour
utiliser effectivement le plus possible
énergie solaire dans tous les pays qui
peuvent le faire c'est bien c'est pas
bien parce qu'on m'a pas aujourd'hui les
énergies fossiles font 80% de l'énergie
qu'on consomme sur terre le solaire sauf
erreur de ma part fait 0 2% ou 0 3 % et
une marge de progression comme dirait
l'autre
oui mais on n'a pas le temps d'attendre
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre que si
on veut les deux degrés je le redis il
faut mettre à la ferraille la totalité
des centrales à charbon dans le monde
dans les 30 ans qui viennent et des
centrales à charbon dans le monde y en a
60 à 30 fois plus que des centrales
nucléaires en france 30 fois plus et
l'énergie solaire on à dieu ça va assez
vite mais est-ce que vous pariez votre
dernière euros d'économies sur le fait
qu'on va y arriver dit oui
non mais tous juin dernier à manger tous
les jours c'est non d'accord on est bien
d'accord donc au fond de vous-même vous
y croyez pas qu'on va y arriver si je
crois qu'il dit ça y est dit on peut
utiliser l'énergie solaire pourquoi pas
en inde ne pourrait pas progressé aussi
alors placé d'autres affaires en inde ce
qu'on pourrait faire en ainsi absolument
on pourrait utiliser du solaire pour
utiliser moins de charbon
c'est tout à fait vrai par contre dire
il n'y a qu'à faire ça et ça va finir
pas réglé le problème moi je dis non
faute eu des envies faut tout ce qu'on a
sous la main je n'ai tout où on prend
tous sont tous prononcés par à dire je
ne savais pas ça et c'est donc de votre
livre chapitre qui m'a étonné celui qui
fait une sorte de corrélation entre
pétrole et front national au national le
parti politique qui ont connaît bien ici
en france et puis le pétrole et vous
dites ils sont dans un bateau
alors j'ai envie de dire aux mêmes
bateaux ça veut dire que quoi l'unss vie
de l'autre quelle est la collection
entre les deux ch aurait commencé par
faire un petit détour
si le front national était un problème
purement français exactement la montée
d'un parti dit populiste était un
problème purement français ça ne devrait
pas se passer au bac bomans ailleurs or
vous constaté qu'aujourd'hui on est en
train de voir des montées de partis
populistes sécessionnistes enfin bref
des gens qui disent ça va plus on veut
vivre notre vie de notre côté un peu
partout en europe il ya des vrais nazis
au parlement grec
vous avez des sécessionnistes en
catalogne vous avez enfin bref ça monte
partout et vous avez l'extrême droite
qui fait son apparition dans les pays
scandinaves qui sont pourtant souvent
érigée en modèle de démocratie
donc c'est que vous avez apprennent plus
systémique qui est en train de
s'appliquer à l'europe
et ce problème plus systémique c'est la
décrue
énergétique imposé c'est ça que j'essaie
d'expliquer et en particulier celle du
pétrole en quelque chose qui va
peut-être surprendre les gens qui nous
écoutent parce qu'en ce moment le prix
du baril est badgée retient comment ça
se fait que ce soit le cas l'europe
aujourd'hui consomme 18% de pétrole en
moins qu'elle n'en consommait en 2006 et
c'est pas parce que borloo royal et les
autres ont été particulièrement
efficaces c'est parce que la production
mondiale de pétrole a cessé d'augmenter
en 2005 le vrai pétrole ce qui sort de
terre sous forme de pétrole ça s'est
arrêté d'augmenter en 2005
on est plus en plus nombreux autour de
la table de repas donc les pays
producteurs ont une consommation
domestique qui augmente les pays les
infractions riche des émergents et
notamment les 400 millions de chinois
qui vivent comme des américains
aujourd'hui à tous ceux de la cote
auprès des européens à l'arrière en
consomment de plus en plus et il ya une
plus d'argent ces gens là que les
classes moyennes françaises et donc il
en reste moins pour les importateurs
historique de la zone ocde
ça touche le japon ça touche toute
l'europe ça a même touché les états unis
qui consomment moins de pétrole
aujourd'hui qu'en 2006
nonobstant tout ce qu'on a pu raconter
sur le sur le pétrole de schiste
la décrue du pétrole force la décrue des
échanges puisque le pétrole et l'énergie
des échanges c'est ce qui fait rouler
les camions ou les voitures volées les
avions et c'est sa force la décrue des
échanges et donc sa force
la décrue de la production industrielle
et la production industrielle baisse
dans tous les pays européens depuis 2007
tous sauf l'allemagne pas cause de ses
exportations sa baisse au japon ça a
même baissé aux états unis ça se
redressent un peu à cause de leur
production énergétique domestique mais
sinon ça baisse partout et dans la
foulée de ce truc là les emplois baisse
dans un certain nombre de secteurs
et ça ça fait monter les populistes
parce que la détresse du chômage et le
truc qui nourrit les populistes et
l'endroit où ça se manifeste plus et je
vais finir par ça en france et à 40 km
du centre des villes c'est l'ifop a
sorti une étude très intéressante là
dessus et la raison que j attribue la
suivante c'est là que vous allez trouver
les gens qui continuent à avoir besoin
de la ville pour travailler mais qui ont
les revenus les plus bas
donc c'est ce qu'ils vont aller qui va
avoir besoin d'aller le plus loin pour
trouver un logement
s'ils ont les revenus les plus bas à ses
excès les moins qualifiés donc c'est les
premiers à éjecter quand le système
économique va pas bien et si système
économique va pas bien parce qu'on n'a
pas assez de pétrole c'est aussi ce qui
en même temps vont avoir le plus de mal
à se déplacer
pour moi la voiture et donc ils sentent
abandonnés et indépendamment
immigré ou pas d'immigrés ils votent
avec leurs pieds et c'est exactement ce
qui fait la montée des extrémismes dans
ce genre de terreau merci beaucoup jean
marc jancovici était l'invité du club de
la presse charles cros lycée qui s'il se
livre donc chez odile jacob dormez
tranquilles jusqu'en 2100 et autre
malentendu sur le climat de l'énergie
marcio co